so today's draft
the all-time
other guys in nfl history that second
guy that guy that you ordinarily don't
think about who was a key part of a
given team championship whatever the
case may be big cat no trivia question
today i'm just gonna i'm in a good mood
today under the circumstances i'm gonna
let you have the first pick i'm gonna
let you go you're gonna oh wow yeah all
right i'm gonna let you go i'm gonna all
right my first pick
wait a minute i thought you said you're
gonna let me go
i know i'm gonna let you guys a little
mind trick right there no go ahead go
ahead
no go ahead okay
all right i'm gonna go with reggie wayne
indianapolis colts receiver the other
guy to marvin harrison what
what nothing i'm just getting you off
your game right away it's great uh uh
that's all right i actually prepared for
this when you didn't i wasn't the one
who asked the producers during the last
commercial send me a list of
possibilities so i'm ready for this
reggie wayne the guy's gonna make it to
the hall of fame right i don't think
he's the other guy i think everyone had
everyone knew reggie wayne but he still
is but he still is the other guy it's
marvin harrison he's the other guy you
can't have two guys he's the other guy
reggie wayne's the other guy to marvin
harrison
so then would you just
would under those rules chris carter be
the other guy to randy moss
potentially if you want to pick chris
carter potentially you could do that no
you could do that won't be my i think
it's actually a good pick um i'll go uh
another great player great other guy
harry carson other guy to lt on those
giant giant defenses so that's my first
other guy great pick by me
that's actually not a bad pick i hadn't
considered harry carson but again i can
make the same argument you did the guy
uh the hall of famer in his own right
how can he be the other guy if he's a
hall of famer right
so yeah so anyway i i i like that i like
that all right um i got a bunch of
different directions i can go and the
question is how many of these do i hold
because you're probably not going to
take them
um
i'll tell you the first one that sticks
out to me the classic other guy who when
he had a chance to be the guy fell flat
on his face alvin harper from the
cowboys of the early 90s remember alvin
harper the other guy to michael irvin
the guy who would step up with the big
catch i think he had a huge catch in one
of the nfc championship games against
the 49ers i kind of have a vague memory
of that seeing him make the big catch
from troy aikman
he signed
somewhere as a free agent i can't even
remember who he signed with that's how
that's how
poorly it went for him when he finally
got a chance to be the guy was it tampa
bay
let's let's uh let me know uh control
room on where alvin hyper finally signed
it was the tampa bay buccaneers uh he
never did anything as the number one guy
but was the perfect other guy to michael
irvin
okay good pick i actually i'm let me
throw out an other guy i'll take a pause
in my next pick but let me throw out
another guy
that i don't think is another guy but i
just want to throw out for discussion
would you say
that uh who would be the other guy in
keenan mcardle
and uh jimmy smith who would be the
other guy are they both the guy
it's kind of they're they're both
i mean smith had more production
um but it's not like he didn't have her
name
keenan had a cooler name well is that
that's a factor in your thought process
i i i think that it's closer
i think it's closer neither guy was just
like off the charts hall of fame level
but jimmy smith burned very very
brightly for a you know a period of time
okay uh all right that was just a
question just a little point of order
just wondering if we wanted to discuss
that all right my next other guy is a
guy that everyone knows and uh has been
kind of an other guy for his entire
career that's darren sproles other guy
hall of fame in my opinion he is always
you know he was behind the guy who
though who's the other guy
in tomlinson
in his best years in san diego i mean he
was the other guy so he maybe became the
guy a little bit but he's always the
other guy and so uh i think he's he's
one of the best other guys ever because
he's not a featured back he's not a guy
who can carry the ball you know 200 plus
times a year but he's fantastic he's
electric he reminds me actually a lot of
my running back right now at tennessee
jojo smalls
3 p.m is my sec championship game also
reminds me of ricky squeaks at texas
tech i love the uh shorter backs that
that kind of you know squeak by
i remember back when sproles was coming
out of kansas state he was referred to
as a poor man's reggie bush the reality
is he had the career reggie bush was
supposed to have right
sproles became at the nfl level the guy
that bush was supposed to be um
i i other i don't know that he just
because he never really he's
he's not a con there's not two of him on
a team that's my point it's not like
there's a darren sproles and another
darren sproles if he was on a team with
reggie bush and reggie bush was gayle
sayers then darren sproles is the other
guy so i that that one connected
a little bit but
well that's fine that's fine you're but
it's different skills
yes i am
here's one speaking of my age and
something i can relate to rocky blyer
the all-time running back other guy
pittsburgh steelers running back great
story vietnam veteran had a war injury
they did a movie about him he was the
other guy of frank o'hara's key
component of the steelers offense of the
70s back when they actually used two
running backs on a regular basis go back
and watch some of those old games
running backs and receivers in a
three-point stance before the snap it is
jarring to see how different it was and
you the old pro set you had the
quarterback under center and you had two
running backs one on each side and it
was 32 and 20 and rocky blyer was uh in
because
the immaculate reception cemented frank
o'haras as the guy in pittsburgh for as
long as he was going to be there but
rocky blyer a very
very competent very successful and still
a hero in pittsburgh as the other guy in
the 70s
okay i'll go with my last pick
um
[Music]
hmm
by the way i looked up who was the
backup quarterback for chris sims in his
senior year in texas what a name you
ready for it you probably never heard
this name
you ready for it
chase mock
chase mock
how's that a name chase mock yeah
i i uh well yeah i well i don't even
know what inspired you to look that up
but yes that was a stranger to maybe see
if if chris had uh you know someone or
he was the other guy to someone else i
guess he was yeah to major applewhite
major at boys
right yeah but chase mock what a name
uh all right i'll go with my last one i
will go with um let's go let's go jerome
brown after reggie white that's a good
pick that's a good pick the other guy
yeah yeah clyde simmons i mean it's a
four-man unit so this is more conducive
to when you have two you got one you got
the other thing i'm not going to quibble
with you on that one other guys also
works
i i here's one that i have i'm going to
go a fourth round because we got a
couple of minutes you mentioned chris
carter
okay well you you you mentioned chris
carter because my i've been i've been
getting my son to do my my work for me
on these drafts and give me ideas he
said chris carter also and i said son
actually
the ultimate other guy from that 98
vikings team is jake reed
time out what time out what time out can
we go backwards for a second when you
said uh yeah you needed help with this
draft and you just admitted that your
son is just building the drafts for you
so
let's just get this on the record let's
just get out of the record because this
is great this is great because we want
to slip up by you i am nine i'm
two
generations of florio when i draft two
generations i've taken out your whole
family tree every time we do this draft
on fridays
my son is gradually being introduced
into the business and i'm getting him
involved in ways that i can and i'm
getting his input on these draft picks
and he said chris carter and i said
let's take it one step farther jake reed
they had the hats made up that said
three deep jake reed was a big part of
that team is one of the only draft picks
that panned out in the aftermath of the
herschel walker trade he was with the
vikings for a decade or so
and he was a very very competent
receiver for the vikings so if you think
moss and carter moss and carter the
other guy is jake reed so give me jake
reed
okay uh what about uh bill belichick to
bill parcells the other guy
you could say buddy ryan too i thought
of buddy ryan bill but i lie that's all
right i could i could go with that
no i could go with something not anymore
but yeah buddy ryan's actually a good
one buddy ryan is definitely a good one
you know tying it all the way back to
the uh super bowl being on nbc sports 3
p.m on sunday nice little plug by me uh
that's a good one that's a very very
good one other guy
all right well i think we have exhausted
the topic but it was some fun and uh
we're going to revisit it wait wait wait
wait let me see it go ahead can i see
the can i see the ending can i see the
draft
then they have it oh they have it there
we go
why did you want to see it
well because i was gonna i was obviously
gonna grade it i barely won this one but
i did win this one but i'll get i'll
tell you this mike you gave me your best
shot today that was as close as it's
been in a while
maybe even the rivalry is back on even
though you haven't beat me yet
thanks are you done
two generations
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports